Walter White entered the criminal
underworld as a desperate dying man who
just wanted to leave his family off well
before his departure but he quickly
became addicted to the power and thrill
of being a kingpin and is sucked into
the Empire business yet you would expect
a Caltech wizard who has contributed to
a Nobel Prize and even had a
multi-billion dollar company built
office research to have been better with
his money in the first place as albert
einstein said the most powerful force in
the world isn't the speed of light dark
matter or black holes but compounding
interest so here's how much money Walter
White would have had if he had just
invested his money
[Music]
starting off we know that Walter Wyatt
lives a pretty frugal life Walter and
Schuyler both drive pretty old cars and
they live in what they thought would
just be their starter home they don't
spend money on anything that seems
lavish or unnecessary so it's likely
that Walter White was actually saving
and investing but of course that would
make for an interesting story let's
first take a look at the most accessible
investment option for Walter White for
most Americans
this would be a 401k or a Roth IRA but
since Walter is a teacher and toss a
government employee the easiest
investment tool available to him would
be a 403 B plan and yes this is offered
by Albuquerque Public Schools this is
basically a 401k plan for teachers where
money will be deducted every month
straight from their paycheck tax-free
and invested for them the only
difference is that 401 k plans are
generally more efficient and have lower
fees than 403 B plans before we get into
the numbers let's set up some base
assumption we know that Walter left gray
matter in the early 1980s and he won the
Nobel Prize recognition in 1985 when
they were house shopping we can see that
Skyler was pregnant with Walter jr. and
that Walter was working for Sandia
laboratories so it's likely that he
became a teacher in the 1990s in the
show he gets fired in 2009 and dies in
September of 2010 but if he didn't turn
to a dark side he wouldn't have gotten
fired and his death would have been
significantly delayed we know that he
had significant remission and it's
likely that without all the stress in
danger of the criminal world and without
ghetto chemotherapy for six months he
would have lived a good amount longer so
we'll say that under normal
circumstances he wouldn't have died till
September of 2012 assuming that he
started working at Sandia laboratories
in 1987 this means that he would have
had right about 25 years of working time
on top of this it's very likely that he
made more at
Indian laboratories that he does as a
teacher but we'll assume he only made
his teacher salary of forty three
thousand seven hundred a year the entire
time this general rule for retirement
contribution is ten percent of one's
gross salary so we'll set up Walter puts
in four thousand three hundred and
seventy dollars per year now during
those exact 25 years the S&P 500 or what
is regarded as the market grew on
average eight point six zero three
percent per year what dividends
reinvested even if Walters 403 B plan
didn't match the market and only got
seven percent yearly returns and charged
a very high 1.5% yearly fee Walter would
get five point five percent growth every
single year at this rate Walter would
only contribute one hundred nine
thousand two hundred fifty dollars over
25 years but his investment would
actually be worth over double that at
two hundred twenty three thousand
dollars by the end and that's the very
minimum he would have two hundred twenty
three thousand dollars if he was
completely ignorant to everything and
just mindlessly contributed ten percent
per year now a significant benefit of
using employer-provided investment
platforms is that they often have
employer match meaning that they'll
contribute up to a certain amount this
is generally up to ten percent of one's
total income so in Walters case employer
match will provide up to another four
thousand three hundred and seven dollars
per year assuming that Walter School
District contributes fifty cents for
every dollar Walter contributes with
Walter contributing four thousand three
hundred and seven dollars per year the
school district would contribute two
thousand one hundred eighty five dollars
per year adding to a total of six
thousand five hundred fifty five dollars
per year using the same time span and
growth as before with employer match
Walter would have a solid three hundred
and thirty-five thousand dollars but
what if Walter contributed morning ten
percent Walter doesn't make too much to
start with so he can't be contributing
forty to fifty percent of his salary but
we know that Skyler worked at Beneke
fabricators at one point and Walter work
at a car wash as a side job so it's
possible that he was able to contribute
a solid twenty percent of it
sorry per year taking full advantage of
template match now that's the highest
we'll go as anything higher would
require insane frugality and or would be
unrealistic but 10 to 20% contribution
is quite reasonable if Walter invested
eight thousand seven hundred forty
dollars per year with no employment
match he'd be left with four hundred
forty-seven thousand dollars but if he
also had employment match this amount
would balloon up to six hundred and
seventy thousand dollars nearly the
737,000 he originally wanted so by just
taking advantage of employee retirement
plans Walter would have two hundred
twenty three thousand to six hundred
seventy thousand dollars an exponential
improvement from the laughable $8,700 he
actually had his life savings after
nearly a lifetime of work will say he
had in between those estimates at 500
thousand dollars now of course he still
has to pay for all the cancer treatment
which would significantly reduce his
family's inheritance
according to Walters calculations it
would cost three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars for two kids college
education 107 thousand to pay off the
house and 30 K for the equity line on
top of this he wants to leave behind 2 K
per month for 10 years starting off with
his hospital bills usually most
hospitals are actually very
understanding a financial hardship and
offer a loan reduction and or no
interest payments but we'll assume that
Walter would classify these as handouts
and charity and that he is determined to
pay off the full amount we know Walter
surgery cost one hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and that his
chemotherapy it cost tens of thousands
so will cause total medical bill three
hundred thousand dollars as for the
house payments the thirty thousand
dollar equity line and one hundred and
seven thousand dollar mortgage balance
would cost one hundred thirty seven
thousand dollars total now Walter
usually wouldn't be able to withdraw
from his forwards Phoebe till he is
fifty nine and a half years old but
Walter would more than qualify for a
financial hardship withdrawal the
qualified circumstances for early
withdrawal without penalties are large
medical bills a down payment on a
primary residence higher education
tuition fees
Division / foreclosure furthermore
medical bills are tax deductible above
7.5% of once adjusted gross income with
Walters salary everything above 3000
$278 will be tax deductible or basically
99% of the entire medical bill this
would leave Walter with $200,000 in his
retirement account which would be more
than enough for the 137 thousand dollar
mortgage balance and every line however
this 200k would be subject to income tax
which comes out to a hefty sixty one
thousand four hundred seventy five
dollars but Walter would have just
enough to pay both of these off and he
would have about 1500 left as for Walter
jr. and holly's agitations let's be
honest here if he hadn't gotten cancer
or gotten involved in a drug business he
wouldn't have contributed much to the
education working as a high school
chemistry teacher with eighty seven
hundred dollars in savings anyways one
thing to consider however is that if
Walter didn't get into the drug business
he may have stuck with his original
decision to not get cancer treatment and
this will allow him to leave behind a
solid three hundred thousand dollars
going at 5.5 percent so even if Walter
was just a mediocre investor relying on
his 403 B or the S&P 500 he would have
been able to leave his family off with
no liabilities and three hundred
thousand dollars by rejecting medical
treatment not bad but what if Walter was
a genius investor just like he was a
genius chemist well assuming he
contributed twenty percent of his salary
towards investing every year he'd be
able to invest 8740 dollars per year and
above average return on investment would
be ten percent per year and this is
realistically what Walter would hope for
and a 10 percent auto why he would have
eight hundred fifty nine thousand
dollars at the time of his death ideally
you would liquidate these positions over
several years in order to reduce capital
gains taxes but even if Walter
liquidated the entire amount in one year
he would retain 80 percent of his
investment leaving him with $687,000
this would be enough to pay for his
entire medical treatment and home
liabilities and he would have two
hundred fifty thousand dollars
left Walter estimates that Walter jr.
and Holly's education will cost three
hundred and sixty thousand dollars but
instead of being one hundred eighty
thousand dollars each it's likely one
hundred fifty thousand for Walter jr.
and two hundred ten thousand for Holly
due to inflation after paying for Walter
juniors education as well as all of his
liabilities and medical bills Walter
could leave behind $100,000 for Skyler
ideally Skyler would invest this into a
safe index fund after Walters death and
get a job herself to cover monthly
living expenses considering that holly
was born in between late 2008 and early
2009 she would go to college in 2027
meaning that there would be 15 years of
growth before she needs the money had a
modest 7% rate Walt's $100,000 would
have grown to two hundred and seventy
five thousand dollars after taxes this
would be exactly enough for Holly's
education so if Walter invested his
money and got above average returns of
ten percent he could have covered all
the big expenses in his family's life
Skyler would simply have to take care of
monthly living expenses like food
utilities repairs and so on and so forth
so those are the realistic outcomes but
now let's take a brief look at if you as
an exceptional investor if he got 15%
early returns this would grow to a total
of one point eight five nine million
dollars after 25 years which would be
enough to cover everything plus have
roughly a million dollars left and
lastly if Walter was a world-renowned
investor he could get returns of 20.5%
per year which is what Warren Buffett
has maintained since 1965 this route
would leave Walter with a nice four
point four seven million dollars
something to keep in mind is that this
is all off of a forty three thousand
seven hundred
Walter graduated from Caltech where the
median starting salary itself is roughly
twenty-five thousand dollars more than
Walters final salary the median
mid-career salary at Caltech is 124
thousand dollars and considering Walters
additional qualifications he likely
could have landed a job at paying 150
thousand dollars in the chemistry field
given the higher salary he could easily
afford to put a higher proportion of his
income towards investing if he put 33%
towards investments or 50k per year even
at an average 7% yearly return he would
have had 3 point 1 6 million dollars and
with Warren Buffett level returns he
could have had 25 point 5 million
dollars he likely wouldn't have gotten
that high but with a nice paying lap job
and good investing habits Walter could
have quite reasonably pushed upwards of
5 to 10 million by the time he died
completely legally and by the time
Skyler dies she could pass down about 30
million dollars just investing index
funds considering that Walt was only
able to pass downn 10 million after
risking his life several times
nationally shaming his entire family and
dying alone it definitely seems like
Walter was in the wrong Empire business
but that's just what I think what do you
guys think Walter should have done
comment that down below also if you guys
like the depth of this analysis then
make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]